[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати,
село Космач]
Постіл не має ні нитки,
ні цвяха ніякого, нічого.
Гуцул придумав:
складає взуття зі шматка шкіри.
Таке наші предки робили.
Та й ми продовжуємо.
[Тарас Дзвінчук
Постоляр]
Хотіли жінки одягнутися в національний одяг,
то й треба було до цього і постоли.
У середньому
одну-дві пари в тиждень роблю.
Сухе не складеш,
із сухої шкіри не можеш зробити.
Вона розмокає і стає м'якша.
Мені було 20 років, коли батько помер.
Його вуйко [дядько],
чи якийсь родич навчив.
Ну а я біля тата щось помагав,
то й трохи вже вмів.
Я залишився [один]
і так почав жити.
Та й люди вже самі приходили...
Основне — аби пошити.
Та й так зайшло,
і от вже 46 років, як я це роблю.
Був у Косові
і бачив у кіоску постоли,
що в мене купили за 600,
а там вони уже 1600.
У кожному селі
були майстри постолів.
А зараз уже нема.
Я залишився тут,
а з Верховинського району сім'ї їдуть
і жінки їдуть сюди до мене,
бо немає там майстрів.
Шкіра дорога, по 300-350 людина
заплатила за шкіру,
принесла — це вже теж є відповідальність.
Щоб їй то зробити.
Та й жінці не так і легко вгодити.
Аби їй все підійшло:
так, як вона хоче.
І розмір, і прикраси
нелегко.
Основне — копито.
Це називається копитом — щоб надати йому форму.
Це теж не легко зробити.
Копито, аби обидва постоли були однаковими.
Правий і лівий —
це основне.
Краса постола залежить від цієї форми, від копита.
Надаємо вже першу форму.
Переважно чоловічі постоли роблю без прикрас.
Тисну писаками,
відтискаю візерунки.
А жінкам прикрашаю лелітками,
щоб у них блистіли.
Знаєте, як гуцулка взує такі постоли,
то чоловіки лиш дивляться на її ноги.
Постіл — це уже розкіш.
Це не буденне взуття,
щоб купити, а вже за місяць...
Колись гуцулці, як вона виходила заміж,
робили цілий гуцульський одяг,
і вона у цьому йшла до церкви, вінчалася.
І потім цей одяг лиш на свята одягала,
та так його шанувала,
що сказала, як вона помре —
то в цей самий одяг,
у якому вона приймала шлюб,
то щоб одягали її в цей одяг
і ховали так.
Ну, зараз уже цих традицій,
певно, так не дотримуються.
А колись взагалі постоли —
то була необхідність, не було...
[стукає молотком по шкірі]
...що одягати і це одягали
буденно і взимку,
і влітку.
Заношували до дір.
Тоді підшивали ще одну шкіру.
Бідували люди...
Ми повільно наближаємося
до завершення.
Мають бути запаски, щоб
взагалі коліна закривали.
Все вже коротке, до того не пасує.
Вишита сорочка,
кептар такий, з овечої
шкіри з капслями [бляшані кільця] навіть.
Там набивають такі
прикраси,
і така гуцулка виходить,
як писанка, різнокольорова.
Одягнути копито,
і це вже він має сохнути.
Висохне вже завтра
і буду виписувати писаками.
Це йде отак,
навколо ноги.
[Дмитро Линдюк
Майстер запасок]
Розкладаєш,
береш дві бабіни [котушки],
дві отакі червоні,
тут собі зав'язуєш,
і на скільки хочеш метрів —
на 40, 50, 60 —
і отак крутиш.
Така технологія.
З цього робиться така коса.
Одягаєш її на палки
і накручуєш.
Спочатку снуємо,
потім набираємо.
Треба три людини,
кожному, бачите, скільки тут є
цих «кобилок», набираєш,
накручуєш це все
і вже потім тчеш собі.
Така технологія.
Треба йти вліво-вправо.
«Зомитися» називається.
Є чотири поножі, бачите,
їх ногами перебираєш.
Кожна дівчина має мати запаску,
спершу бере меншу
і йде в колядники, як в нас це називають.
Потім виростає з цього
і вже до шлюбу їй роблять нові.
Запаски для гуцульської жіночої одежі
складаються з двох частин — з передньої і задньої.
Це у нас такий жовтогарячий колір,
у нас і писанки такого гарячого кольору,
так само і запаски.
Це моя мама колись робила,
і я в мами це перейняв.
Малим хлопчиком, 6-7 клас,
вже почав сам сідати за верстат
мама мені дозволяла,
і я собі так полюбив цю роботу.
Я закінчив Сторожинецький лісовий технікум, працював лісником 25 років  у Космачі,
але попри це я й займався й цим.
Колись жінки багато робили в нас.
Усе на цьому сиділи, полотно ткали,
так, колись жінки ще ткали тут полотно.
Тепер уже готове з Білорусії.
Полотно вже не вигідно робити вручну.
А запаски ми мусимо робити,
не знаю, може хтось винайде,
може, китайці щось придумають.
Якщо працювати цілий день, то можу дві зробити.
Одну жінку ніби на одну пару.
Але треба це від ранку до вечора робити.
Бо тут не можна помилятися.
Як витягнеш якусь не ту нитку —
то вже можна викидати.
Його розібрати назад не можна.
Пройшов 10 сантиметрів — вже не розбереш.
Якийсь час робив багато за кордон,
були замовлення туди для українських ансамблів.
І в Канаду, і в Америку,
в Англію.
Це така робота, що тут треба
і щоб стан стояв, бо поперек болить,
плечі печуть,
ноги мають здорові бути і зір має бути.
Я можу робити кожного дня, проблем немає.
Нічого, слава Богу, не болить,
Тут треба мати терпеливість,
хотіти сидіти і це робити,
любити цю роботу.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Андрій Сачева]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Музика
Роялькіт]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]